Well, the potential damage to the economy is not just a short-term threat.
There will certainly be a longer-term impact as well.
Our economics editor Faisal Islam has been looking in more detail at the latest forecasts.
A month down the road and still surreal scenes of a closed country,...
...the cogs of the economy paused to give space to protect public health.
But it's not without its own cost.
And today, the government's own internal forecaster...
...set out what that could be if these scenes last for a further two months.
The numbers are huge.
Britain's economy could shrink by 13 percent in 2020...
...in the case of a three-month coronavirus lockdown.
That would be a far larger contraction...
...than seen during the financial crisis over a decade ago, the World Wars,...
...and the only precedent is the depression of 1920 to 21.
Or if there is a bounce back; it won't be under their scenario until next year.
This means permanent damage and government borrowing at 14 percent of the size of the economy,...
...the highest since World War II.
If you were to see the sort of decline in GDP...
...that we think will be consistent with a three-month lockdown,...
...then you wouldn't have seen a quarterly fall in the economy like that in living memory.
The hope though, is that, that is gonna be a temporary rather than a permanent problem...
...that we don't end up scarring the long-term potential of the economy.